are you Greg you there Greg he's there
I'm here how are you Greg are you where
do we have bluetooth issues is there a
bluetooth issue I did I had to get it
turned on and I'm still a little bit of
mourning over my feelers man so it's
been a rough it's rough
hey Greg I gotta tell you man I don't
know a tomlin to me is a coach worthy of
every every worth every penny and we
have no idea what he's been dealing with
zero zero basketball all right so let's
talk about storming locker rooms levar
ball and on the court let's talk about
all three of those issues right in all
seriousness though what do you what is
your concern about the Cavs well I'd
love for you to weigh in on this issue
should there be any concern for them at
all Greg there's any other way to put it
there they're basically a bad basketball
team and they'd been like this the last
four years basically in part because of
their age this year you factor and
trying to integrate all these new pieces
there's a lot of thinking going on on
that roster and not a lot of playing and
there's gonna be bad probably four oh
man I would take the next three weeks
until you get out there Thomas playing
at the best he can be at and then they
work off of that it's going to continue
to struggle because they're never going
to be a great defensive team but they
can become a lot better once they get
rotation solidified and everybody kind
of knows their role but that's going to
take time and they're going to continue
to struggle that and then you couple the
fact that you know Boston and Toronto
those are improved basketball teams in
the Eastern Conference in particular and
really if you look at the entire East
you know even teams that Orlando perfect
example it's not the easy win that it
might have been a year or two ago so
it's going to be a struggle form having
said all of that I still don't know that
I see anybody in the East beating them
for Tottenham how once we get to the
postseason because it's going to be a
different animal it looks it we have the
same conversation last year about this
same time and they could
you two play poorly throughout the rest
of regular season they only won 51 games
last year yet they basically ran
roughshod through that Eastern
Conference although it's improved
I think the roster is improved as if
their team hasn't yet so then who's the
team that you think has the best chance
of knocking off the Warriors whether
it's in the finals or to knock the
Warriors out from achieving the finals
Greg as we're in the halfway point the
Warriors are clearly the favourites to
win the West and to win it all it's
going to be a tremendous challenge for
anybody again to beat them four times
but listen I do think that the Rockets
present the best opportunity out west if
they're right I just think that dr. Dino
had a chance because they are a decent
defensive team and obviously they're
probably only team in the West and you
look at them you can honestly say has
the firepower because even if you defend
the Warriors well you're still going to
have to score you know how to 10 on 15 a
night to have a chance to win that
series and they forget the best
challenge San Antonio I'm really worried
about because I don't think while then
it's going to get back to the Kawhi
Leonard level we saw a year ago OKC I
think it's an interesting storyline I
think it'd be a fun matchup but I just
don't think they have enough depth when
you start looking at their bench and
they still have other issues trying to
integrate their big three I just think
it's going to be the Warriors ultimately
unless unless something happens to them
these are the injuries I'm just it's
going to be a challenge for anybody our
way well the refs might be just eject
all starting five based on what we've
seen Oh on occasion is there how do you
how do you Greg knowing what's going on
on the court having been in this game
yourself how do you lift the lid off of
this boiling pot and turn the
temperature down between the zebras and
the players right now Greg yeah I think
unless and I'm glad to see that the
commissioner and the head of the MVP a
have gotten together I think they have a
cooler head but it is becoming a
significant injury issue in terms of the
relationship between players
and the officials and I do think both
sides deserve some blame here I mean
this is not all on the players or on the
officials but but both deserve a
significant amount of blame and quite
frankly this could be something from a
PR standpoint that could really hurt the
lead down the line right now it's kind
of an underlying story but if this thing
continues on the path that's on I think
it's going to become somewhat
detrimental to the overall success of
the league is starting to enjoy and in
they're gonna have to do something about
it in listen I'm not one of criticize
officials ever because yeah do they miss
calls of course they do just like
Klara's miss shots and turn the ball
over they make mistakes every game the
difference was there used to be
listening roughly a little miss a call
and he said you know what Greg I missed
that one I owe you one
now knew damn well he wasn't gonna make
it up to me but I out the fact that he
acknowledged okay I made the mistake
I can live with that right because
there's a player I know they're gonna
miss calls so that's something I'll tell
you another thing we talked about this
on the show I think because of the way
to gain exchange they're gonna have to
seriously think about having four
officials because you have to defeat
them now officiate a much larger court
if you think about the half court when I
play you're worried about one guy
shooting a three now that entire court
is spaced out to 30 30 to 33 feet
there's a lot more ground you have to
cover as an individual official and I
think that would help exacerbate or I
should say that that would help to
alleviate some of the issues but right
now overall the relationship hasn't been
great and the officiating hasn't been as
good as we've seen in years past and
again those are those are legitimate
issues that the league may not want to
address but I've know internally it's a
concern how do you think draymond would
take let's add one more on the floor he
wants all 70 gun but I just think it's
something to consider because the games
just evolved man Ritchie you and I I've
been around long time when when I was a
young where and
when you were working at another Network
the game was so drastically different
the skill level was different you guys
weren't shooting from 28 30 feet you
weren't running off that's 35 people in
the basket you know you were trying to
get it into a certain area so they have
to cover more ground matter that's just
reality it's a harder game to officiate
because of that you know because you've
got a you got a the fit you got a
referee now more on 30-foot jump shots
can you ever have to think about how
rare was to get a four point point
opportunity in the NBA ten years ago now
you basically get a few every game you
know so that tells you that the
officiating has changed and it's just
another issue that they're gonna have to
address but but overall man it's it's
been a fun watch in terms of the game
and I'm starting to get excited about
all started well I look forward to
seeing you out here in Los Angeles Greg
I appreciate you taking the time here on
the show you bet we'll chat soon
interesting stuff from Greg Anthony at
Greg Anthony 50 the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience